citing the war's growing toll on
civilians in ukraine the un general
assembly demanded an immediate cessation
of hostilities from russia and called on
its troops to withdraw
140 nations voted for the resolution
backed by ukraine and nato allies
so it just shows again
that when the
international communities ask to take a
stand
russia
is isolated
and the appeal
today of the general assembly is
directed primarily towards russia and we
just hope that this time they will heed
that call
russia was joined by only four allies
north korea belarus syria and eritrea in
opposing the resolution which also
demands an end to the size of mario poll
but 38 countries abstained from the vote
among them china
it's clear that some of the contents of
the draft resolution go beyond the scope
of humanity some issues are very complex
and can only be resolved through
political negotiations between the
parties concerned china favored a
resolution submitted by south africa
with more moderate language one calling
for an immediate cessation of
hostilities that didn't single out
russia
once war has begun
it is imperative that all of us
work towards peace
it is for this reason
that south africa is the of the view
that right now
we should be more concerned with ending
the war and addressing the humanitarian
pride of the people that are impacted by
it
that resolution was submitted but never
put to a vote after ukraine raised
procedural objections
this tax has never been a product of
consultations with ukraine neither it is
a product of cross-regional consultation
as was the case with the resolution just
adopted by overwhelming majority
it is a tax promoted unilaterally by one
country prompted by another country
unlike the security council resolutions
in the general assembly are legally
non-binding but still symbolically
important even countries who abstained
from the vote expressed grave concern at
the humanitarian situation for
ukrainians but argued a resolution
supported by all countries would be more
effective even if the vast majority of
countries believe russia is ultimately
responsible
kristen salumi al-jazeera the united
nations